what are you gonna name the bus I don't
know we're still talking about it I feel
like a name will come to us in the next
couple days on the tour but for now it's
just deep for America bus I mean we've
talked a little bit about this earlier
you big names have have been able to
rent a bus a lot of your colleagues
running are not going to be able to rent
a bus true what and it is just a vehicle
has just but it's it's a symbol of you
hitting a certain threshold that others
are not going to be able to hit well I
mean I don't want to overstate the
meaning of the bus but this is the time
to have a full-blown campaign to
demonstrate that you can compete that
you can have a strong state operation
and a strong national operation so this
is part of it the greatest part of it of
course is the staff we've got a hundred
people on the ground here in Iowa and
when we had the steak fry just the the
the level of organization even the
number of t-shirts those little things
add up to demonstrate the kind of
strength that you've got and you know
this is what all those resources are for
all the work that we do to make sure
we're bringing resources into the
campaign is so we can plow it into the
ground in a place like Iowa and earn the
votes that are gonna help us win early
next year because Iowa must win I think
we got to do well here I think that
definition will become a little clearer
in the wintertime but yes we've got to
do well in Iowa look first of all the
best way to settle any question about
electability is to win an election
somewhere secondly I was very good place
for us to campaign it reminds me of home
it's got a similar feel and because of
the way the caucuses work it really puts
a premium on the relationships that only
a well-organized team can build and
we've got a team that is developing a
reputation for being great to work with
having a nice touch we're very proud of
that
and and working to build that up and I
think as this winnowing down of
candidates continues you're still going
to see a lot go into caucus night in
Iowa you won't see very many come out
you're 37 married gay man military
veteran Rhodes Scholar mayor of a small
town
is there something else about you that
America should know well all kinds of
things and that's what we're seeking to
demonstrate on the campaign but I think
the biggest thing is to think about what
kind of president you want I am
passionate about this country but as I
think anybody who sees me knows I'm not
inclined to holler or wave my arms about
it I think America is ready for more or
less the opposite of the president we've
got now and it's important for me to
demonstrate not just in terms of the the
policies I want to put forward but
frankly the style of presidency I want
to create one that makes everybody feel
included one that establishes a sense of
belonging one that mixes the the
strength that is required to get
something done with the inclusion that's
required to make all of America part of
this project so we're being told that
you can either have bold action needed
to move our country forward or we can
unify the country and in my view we
absolutely have to do both we won't be
able to do bold things if we're not
unified around we can't be polarized
around something as existential as
climate change or as important as
dealing with health but we also can't
have half measures and we can't just
tinker we got to have solutions that are
as ambitious as anything that's been
tried in the last half-century or we
just won't get the job done and then
we'll still be living in the conditions
that allowed a guy like Donald Trump to
get to be President in the first place
you're a millennial I'm a millennial you
know the knock on Millennials from older
people is that fair what is it that
they're getting wrong about our
generation well I'm not sure that
everybody understands how hard-working
people are in this generation and
they'll definitely be seeing how
hard-working I am just by virtue of the
way this campaign unfolds and the same
is true for everybody on our team I will
say though I've actually been struck by
how many people of the boomer generation
come up to me on rope lines and talk
about their enthusiasm for generational
leadership they're ready to pass the
torch you know three out of the last
four presidents were born within a few
weeks of each other in the summer in
1946
and I think there's an appetite for new
voices new faces and historically that's
how Democrats went now one of the
characteristics that every winning
Democrat has had from Clinton through
back through Carter and to JFK and Obama
too is representing a new generation
coming from not having been in
Washington for too long and I think
folks are ready for that and the party
and in the country House chasten doing
great he's he's got his own road show
going a lot of the time and you know
this is challenging for both of us it's
a challenging thing to do to your
marriage when you we've been married
just over a year but also bringing us
closer together because it's it's an
adventure we're meeting so many people
along the way who tell us what this
campaign but also what what seeing us
campaigning means to them he's soloing
this week and a bunch of fundraisers for
you right he was not just for us he's
working up for some other good causes
too I think he did an event with the
victory fund but yeah he'll go out on
the road he'll do events too and it
allows me to kind of double a double our
presence by being in different parts of
the country at the same time I know you
guys have talked about becoming parents
at some point have you talked about what
heat what we would call him were you to
be elected president well around South
Bend he's the First Gentleman so I
imagine will be the same thing when he's
in the East Wing of the White House - do
you think the nation's ready for a First
Gentleman yeah and I think they're
definitely ready for a First Gentleman
like Chaston he's he's just got a great
way with people he's great with kids
he's passionate about education and he
will do so much to build people up I
can't wait to see him in that room man
you've been generous with your time safe
travels on the bus Thank You Iowa and
we'll see you soon